around 600 BC lip fail ease of Meletis
widely regarded as the first Greek
philosopher as he was the first to give
a purely natural explanation of the
phenomena he observed a key observation
he made was that certain stones such as
amber when rubbed against fur would
exhibit a strange property the amber
seemed to emit an invisible force which
would attract small fibers he assumed
that this rendered the amber magnetic
another force he observed when playing
with lodestones which are naturally
occurring magnets many after him
observed that the contact or friction
with fur seemed to create an imbalance
something was pulled from the fur and
transferred on to other objects now not
only did this result in a small
attractive or repulsive force but also
in the potential for shocks to occur
once the discharge occurred the force
disappeared so the shock was some form
of discharge which reversed the
imbalance created by the friction
throughout history we were also
fascinated with lightning bolts nature's
most passionate displays of power and
aggression those cultures assume this
was a divine force outside the reach of
human hands and was therefore reserved
for the gods
up until the 17th century our
descriptions of it varied from an
invisible and tangible and launderable
agent or even threads of syrup which
elongate and contract and it was
Benjamin Franklin who in 1752 set out to
prove that there was a connection
between lightning and these tiny shocks
due to friction in the famously
dangerous experiment done alone with his
son he led a kite into a thunderstorm
and near the bottom where the thread was
wet he tied an iron key and after some
time he brought his knuckle up to the
key and experienced a series of small
shocks identical to the ones created by
contact with fur this showed that indeed
lightning was simply the same thing as
these household shocks but on a massive
scale and at this time people had begun
to divide materials into two categories
one were objects which would allow or
accept discharge such as gold or copper
which we call electrical conductors and
interestingly these materials are also
generally good at conducting Heat
and number two were objects which would
not allow this discharge such as rubber
or electrical insulators these materials
also seemed to insulate the transfer of
heat and we also began trying to measure
this force that bailey's had encountered
one way to do this was to suspend a
piece of spongy plant called a pith ball
from a thread and when we rubbed an
insulator against fur and brought it
near the pith ball it would pull on it
causing a deflection
if we added more objects we noticed this
deflection increased due to a greater
pulling force
you
we also notice that the shape of
insulators made a difference large thin
insulators seem to exhibit a much
stronger force
and amazingly it was found that
conductors such as copper wire would
transmit this pulling effect over a
distance this was demonstrated by
running a long wire between the pith
ball and the charged insulator when the
object was brought near the wire it
pulled through the wire and deflected
the pith ball instantly when we later
touch the wire with our finger a
discharge occurs and the pulling stops
and the ball is released immediately
people began speculating that this could
be the future of optical Telegraph's and
in 1774 French inventor George Louis
Lesage was one of the first on record to
actually set up this idea he sent
messages through an array of 26 wires
each wire representing a letter of the
alphabet when a discharge occurred at
one end the pith ball would move at the
other the trouble with his Telegraph was
that it only extended between the two
rooms of his house the power of the
deflection was small and difficult to
work with though at the time people were
investigating techniques for generating
larger charge differences in order to
amplify the force involved one
improvement popularized by Alessandro
Volta one year later was an easy way of
generating discharges on demand it was
based on the idea that a charged
insulator could induce or transfer a
charge onto a nearby conducting plate
one needed to merely bring the metal
plate close to the insulator which would
pull on the charge distribution in the
metal plate resulting in an imbalance or
electrical tension in the metal plate
then one could bring their finger to the
plate and a discharge would a curved
then the plate is pulled away using an
insulating handle and an excess charge
would remain trapped in the plate the
plate could then be discharged at will
simply by touching it to a conductor
such as a finger and amazingly this
process can be repeated many times
without recharging the insulating plate
we could then generate many small
discharges at will and by now Benjamin
Franklin was focused on finding out how
to
trap or store up these discharges at
this time he still assumed that
electricity was some sort of invisible
fluid since he knew it could travel
through water so he assumed that water
inside an insulator could hold
electricity what we now call the Leyden
jar was a glass jar with water inside
and a metal probe running at the top
Franklin also wrapped the outside in a
conductive metal when he brought a
charged conductor towards the top probe
a discharge would occur and stay trapped
in the jar more importantly was that the
jar could be charged multiple times each
spark would amplify the charge
separation or electrical tension inside
the jar a good analogy is to think of
the jars of balloons and each discharge
as a short jolt of water and after
hundreds of iterations the tension
becomes massive and to release the
charge he simply touched the outside
conductor to the top probe a large
discharge occurred Franklin improved the
design over time eventually realizing
that the charge was not stored in the
water but the glass the water was merely
a conductive path from the probe to the
jar today we would call the Leyden jar a
capacitor or charge storing device and
when he chained many jars together he
found he could increase the capacity
even more and release deadly bolts of
electricity and over the years people
focused on more effective ways of
building up charge using friction
machines which could then be stored in
capacitors and release
tacular displays of man-made lightning
and over the next 50 years people tried
to design systems for sending sparks
across greater distances using longer
wires and more powerful discharges
however sending electrostatic discharges
as a communication method seemed clumsy
archaic and was no improvement over the
existing optical Telegraph's of the day
they were widely ignored by government
and industry though the tides were
rising an electric revolution was just
around the corner